[Music]
many were quite glad when the
sensational civil trial between amber
heard and johnny depp finally came to an
end just a few weeks ago whether you
actively followed the trial or not you
had zero chance of escaping the media
coverage whereas johnny depp is now back
in talks for an upcoming pirates of the
caribbean amber herd's next appearance
in aquaman in the lost kingdom is on the
horizon
up until now there was word of a mere 10
minutes of screen time for the mirror
actress this had already been determined
regardless of the trial according to
warner brothers president walter hamada
the official reason was the lack of
chemistry between herd and lead actor
jason mamoa
all the more surprising that after the
trial this very small screen time seems
to turn out in favor of amber heard
currently test screenings are running in
front of a selected audience apparently
the cut version with about 20 to 25
minutes of screen time was not as badly
received as initially thought
however this also means that a shorter
screen time will certainly be tested
which is a standard procedure in the
post-production of large films
of course it is hard to say at this
point whether this will be received more
or less well
nevertheless mira may end up being
around a lot longer than first expected
the final result will hit theaters on
march 17 2023
this week there was some news about the
upcoming transformers rise of the beasts
basically characters from the popular
beast wars series are presented here for
the first time in live action format
in addition to megatron it is optimus
primal in particular will make fans
hearts leap for joy
at the transformers fan site the
allspark shows on its website there is
finally a first look at optimus primal
and also bumblebee
there we can see a mask that turns into
a toy figure along with the accompanying
manual
besides the fan site has published an
image of a russian transformers account
it shows optimus primal with fur
elements and bumblebee with his classic
chevrolet camaro components
in summary we can say that both
characters are close to the original and
fit well into the 1990s where the new
movie is supposed to be set optimus
prime will have to deal not only with
autobots and decepticons in the upcoming
transformers rise of the beasts but also
with terracons which are new to the film
series and likewise very dangerous
there's just about a year left until the
official release on june 9th 2023
so hopefully we will soon be able to
take a more official look at optimus
prime optimus primal and many others
work on season two of netflix's huge hit
squid game has recently been announced
with over 1.65 billion hours of streams
the series is by far the most successful
series on the streaming service
therefore the official announcement of
the sequel should not have surprised
anyone
series creator huang dong-hyuk who
worked in the first season for a total
of 12 years will be involved in the
project again
as donghyuk now revealed somewhat
vaguely via the series instagram page we
can expect to see jihoon the front man
the suit from the start and end of the
series as well as chia soo young hee's
boyfriend
young he refers to the red light green
light doll from season 1 who seems to be
getting an upgrade in the form of chia
soo
we can catch a first glimpse of the new
doll in the official announcement teaser
where it is presented in a familiar
manner
there are still many unanswered
questions such as who is really behind
the mysterious organization and how the
story of zheng ho huang the presumed
dead policeman from the first season
will continue
unfortunately there is still no
estimated release date on netflix but we
will surely have to be patient for at
least another year
more information is now available about
a new reality tv series in the squid
game format this is indeed based on the
real squid game concept like the
original the plan is for 456
participants to compete against each
other for the record-breaking prize
money of 4.56 million us dollars the
participants do not have to expect
lethal dangers though many of the
reality shows games are intended to be
based on the netflix series
the format is a collaboration between
studio lambert and the garden and will
be filmed in the near future
brave english-speaking applicants can
opt for the us uk or global version via
squidgamecasting.com
and can enter an initial selection
process through the website
details on games or the release date of
the series are unfortunately not yet
available we'll probably find out more
once the current casting process has
been completed are you going to try your
luck let us know in the comments
week we reported on the new title for
joker 2 which according to the script
cover is stated to be falia do
as the trade papers now unanimously
report harley quinn will indeed play a
leading role in the upcoming joker 2 and
it is also already known who will take
over this part the talk is of the
estaris born actress and multiple grammy
award winner lady gaga who is likely to
be in intense talks about the role at
the moment this would make her the
successor to margot robbie who played
harley quinn quite convincingly in the
suicide squad and birds of prey movies
however robbie would not have been
considered for the role anyway since her
version of harley quinn has nothing to
do with the planned harley quinn from
the joker universe
there is further news about the planned
way of making the film because as the
hollywood reporter informs joker 2 is
supposed to be a true musical this is
especially interesting since lady gaga
won an oscar for her musical performance
in a star is born and joker director
todd phillips was also involved in that
as a producer
in the fan community this news was not
really met with great excitement while
the demand for a joker sequel is quite
high the planned adaptation as a musical
does not really convince many
some even say that director todd
phillips based the first joker movie on
martin scorsese's taxi driver while the
second one seems to be inspired by the
scorsese musical drama film new york new
york
the latter was a real flop at the box
office by the way and plunged martin
scorsese into a deep depression due to
its poor reception however there are
other people who are praising the
courage behind the creative decision for
joker 2 and are at least somewhat
curious
either way the schedule for philiadoo
seems to be progressing at a fast pace
there is no release date yet but we will
keep you posted
two extremely heartwarming family movies
directed by paul king were released in
2014 and 2017 with paddington and
paddington 2.
just recently the cuddly bear gained
further attention after appearing in a
small clip together with the british
monarch on the occasion of queen
elizabeth ii 70th throne anniversary now
after a five-year wait there are
official plans to bring a third
installment to theaters this one is
called paddington in peru and will no
longer be directed by paul king but by
dougal wilson instead
wilson who has worked mainly in the
music and advertising business is now
about to make his first feature film
the shooting is to take place next year
in london in peru
and as producer david heyman announced
there will also be a reunion with the
brown family that's why return of hugh
bonneville sally hawkins and the like is
also regarded as likely
a release date before 2024 is deemed
highly improbable due to the start of
filming in 2023 but we are still waiting
for an official announcement on when
paddington in peru will be released in
movie theaters
almost four years ago spider-man into
the spider-verse became one of the best
animated films of recent times with its
unique style of animation the movie not
only grossed nearly 375 million us
dollars worldwide but was also a huge
hit with the otherwise rather critical
marvel fans
via twitter sony pictures animation now
announced more news on the sequel
spider-man across the spider-verse
there we see an image of the spot will
give miles morales a hard time in the
animated sequel the marvel villain with
spots all over his body is capable of
traveling to any location he wants by
means of his ink spots these portals
will then appear out of nowhere and can
make objects and even people travel to
other dimensions
the whimsical villain's real name is dr
jonathan own he first appeared in the
comics in 1984 and was created by the
duo of al milgram and herb trimp
originally the graduated physicist
worked for kingpin in order to invent a
teleportation machine for him when he
finally manages to open a portal he
steps through it himself and learns
about the so-called spotted dimension
this in turn leads to the characteristic
spots appearing on his body the problem
with his mighty superpower is that he
only has a limited number of spots on
his body and after using them they must
first regenerate for a certain amount of
time this is bound to come in handy for
miles morales in the upcoming film we
are definitely looking forward to seeing
the new villain spider-man across the
universe is scheduled to be released in
theaters on june 2nd
2023 in addition to news about miles
morales there are also new details
regarding peter parker
after the gigantic success of spider-man
no way home the responsible parties
decided to bring the mcu hit back to the
cinema
as can be seen since a few days on the
official twitter account there will be a
new cut version with extra scenes
this bears the humorous name spiderman
no way home the more fun stuff version
and it's an extended cut
included are longer versions of familiar
scenes as well as completely new scenes
that have not yet been shown in theaters
whether these new scenes will also
differ from the bonus material the
released blu-rays is not yet known
the release of the more fun stuff
version is september 2nd 2022
as deadline reported this week sony's
planned one punch man movie adaptation
is finally making progress according to
the article they have found someone to
be in charge of directing the movie and
it is said to be none other than fast
and furious director justin lin the 50
year old directed several parts of the
action franchise in addition to star
trek beyond before dropping out of the
upcoming fast and furious 10 a couple of
weeks ago due to having disagreements
with vin diesel regarding the creative
aspects sony now seems to have taken
advantage of that opportunity and as a
result lynn will be involved in the
production as well as the writing of the
screenplay in addition to directing the
film the two co-writers are jumanji
creator jeff pinkner and venom author
scott rosenberg the story revolves
around saitama who is nothing short of a
superhero his excessive training has
made him so powerful that he can take
down basically any opponent with a
single punch
so far there are 23 manga volumes as
well as two seasons of the anime series
and many fans are eagerly awaiting the
planned movie for the big screen at
present there is no release date but we
will keep you up to date of course
that was the latest news of the week are
you still looking for more content then
check out our last original on black
panther wakanda forever if you haven't
done so already otherwise there's still
some entertainment in the form of a new
trailer for puss and boots 2 the last
wish have fun watching
[Music]